[Music]
so
[Music]
this antithesis is resolved not so much
through the conflict between the two
moments which are pictured as separate
and independent beings their very
independence implies that each of them
in their own self through its notion
must resolve itself
the conflict begins where both cease to
be these minglings of thought and of
independent existence and where they
confront each other only as thoughts
for them they are as specific notions
only in the relation of an antithesis as
independent on the other hand they have
their essentiality outside of their
antithesis
their movement is therefore their own
free and spontaneous movement as then
the movement of the two sides is an
intrinsic movement since it is to be
considered in the sides themselves it is
initiated by that side which is
determined as possessing being in itself
as contrasted with the other
this is depicted as a spontaneous act
but the necessity for its
externalization lies in the notion that
being in itself
which is so determined in the antithesis
has just for that reason
no genuine subsistence
it is therefore that side which has not
being for self but simple being as its
essence that alienates itself from
itself yields to death and thereby
reconciles absolute essence with itself
four in this movement
it manifests itself
as spirit
abstract essence is alienated from
itself it has natural existence and
self-like
actuality this is its otherness or its
sensuous presence is taken back again by
the second othering and posited as
superseded as universal
the absolute essence has thereby come to
be its own self in its sensuous presence
the immediate existence of actuality has
ceased to be something alien and
external for the absolute essence sense
that existence is superseded is
universal
this death is therefore
its resurrection as spirit
paragraph
779 is perhaps hegel at his best in
certain respects and i suppose for some
readers
maybe hegel at his worst and why do i
say that well it's kind of a hinge
paragraph between all this discussion
that's been going on in the previous
paragraphs where we've brought in you
know the distinctions between good and
evil and we're still talking about
representation or picture thinking
uh depiction foreshtelling as opposed to
the concept the grief right which is
important for spirit so we've got all
that stuff on one side and then what do
we have on the other
side of this after we get to the
resurrection as spirit this gigantic
paragraph
780
that goes on for
more than two pages in the miller text
and then we start you know once we get
past that it's kind of
smoother sailing but there's there's a
lot of
moving parts to use that expression here
and
you know so that's one dimension right
we've got the
good and evil
uh you know what's going on with this on
the one side and then this massive
paragraph in which we're talking about
human nature and the divine and
otherness and we get back to evil and
goodness
and in between we have this paragraph
that
uses the term at least in english
antithesis
so many times now actually the
antithesis is going to be gagenzotz
which is what we start out with here
uh the very first sentence the this
antithesis is resolved the auf losing
the the resolution the
reconciliation the undoing of this
giganzatz of two things being literally
opposed to each other uh we've got conf
conflict we've got confronting each
other gay and uber standing we've got a
relation of antithesis which is not gage
and zotz but rather
and gagan gazetson right so there's a
lot of vocabulary of opposition
here and we've got to figure out what's
opposed to what and in what way
we have a
spontaneous or
freyjas not just
uh real curtis
right or or you know just random thing
but a
we could say
free will but deliberate as well to some
degree
movement going on we've got these two
moments
opposed reconciled
happening
and we have uh towards the end
supersession right and
that tells us that there's something
important going on here
developmentally that there's an auf
haven going on right
and so there's a lot of stuff happening
and it's posed in terms of
something that's concrete and very
important at least in i mean it's
important for a lot of religions it's
particularly important for the
crux moment that we're coming to pun
intended
of death right
death is being referenced here
close to the end and it's also being
referenced at the very
end and the rest of it is incredibly
metaphysical
and
rather abstract even though it's
invoking
natural existence right uh not to leak
his designs and
self-like actuality vehicly you could
say that these are being treated in a
rather
abstract needs content to fill it in
kind of manner which is going to happen
in the following
paragraph and so we could ask ourselves
what what the hell's going on here what
is the
reason for this paragraph and you could
say
to center in on
something that hegel is going to tell us
about these
that the whole paragraph
kind of figures into this right in the
well let's read it the antithesis is
resolved not so much through the
conflict the conf between the two
moments which are pictured we'll come
back to that in a moment as separate and
independent beings their very
independence implies that each of them
in its own self
through its notion its begriff
must resolve itself and
that's happening you know on both sides
although more on one side than the other
at this point
but
couldn't we say that this entire
paragraph
is in fact a
working through
of its notion its notion of what of this
splitting this conflict between the two
sides i think we can that's a meta
interpretation that we're bringing in
but i think it can be
kind of helpful
so let's look at both sides of this
conflict
and let's come back to this um
this this
term the conflict between the two
moments which are pictured
as separate and independent beings
okay
four gestalt pictured
represented
represented by who
represented
as what
each of them as a
moment
is supposed to be
representing
itself
to who to the other moment to us the
phenomenologist to spirit
hegel doesn't specify right he just says
well they are
represented
as independent um substandiga right uh
having their own um being on their own
side and now this is where it gets
really really interesting at least from
my perspective and perhaps you will find
this interesting as well
after he says their very independence
zebsdendikeit implies that each of them
in its own self through its notion must
resolve itself he comes back to talk
about the conflict the conflict
begins
where both
cease to be
these minglings
of thought and independent existence
and you know you could say well
what we've got here is on the one side
for each moment
thought gadonka in this case right
and then we have
the
mingling of thought and independent
existence but it's probably better to
see
each moment itself as
both
both sides
mingling
for mesh height right sort of jumbled up
together right
um an essentiality and as thought we'll
get to this in a moment
each side has that
and the moment combines those two and
the conflict arises when we're not
taking each moment
in its wholeness in its totality but
instead looking at it
just alt skedanka you know as thought
so it is you could say
picturing itself now usually thought is
supposed to be something you know closer
to the concept but it can also be
four stellar and so it's it's
understanding itself in relation to the
other there is a conflict a comp a
battle
between the two that is going
on and then he says um so the conflict
begins where they they stop being this
mingling and they're just
thought where they confront each other
only
as thoughts and here we get
you know as i mentioned
a number of different terms being used
the vocabulary we could say of the
contradiction of the gag and zots is
leading us away from gegenzontz and
we're engaging in an analysis of this
contradiction a little bit so they
confront each other right they are gay
they uh gegen
uberstanden they stand
over against each other the gagan of
gaganzatz against
hostile two
and then he goes on a little bit further
and he says
um they are
as specific notions
okay so we had each of them
has its notion and now they are a
specific a
specified bashimta a narrowed in
notion
narrowed begriff right neither of them
is the concept each of them is has its
concept and now that concept is being
narrowed to
just a kind of thought a
specific notion and in their specific
notions
they are in a relationship of as
miller's translating it antithesis and
he uses the word uh relation right but
zee hung they're connected with each
other they can't escape each other and
they are and gagan
gazetston they are sat opposed to each
other
and the end
you know you could read in here
that there's a kind of distance
separating them they're not
like this you know fist to fist they are
you know at a distance and hostile and
wary
of each other
as they try to work through their
notions
and then he goes on and he says um
as independent
they have their essentiality outside of
this antithesis so not all of what they
are is in this
fight this conf
this struggle with each other each of
them exists on their own side
as independent as an essentiality
a vasently kite not just a vason but as
a vasently kite a being essential uh
having the condition
of essentiality outside of this
antithesis and so here's where he says
this movement is therefore their own
free and spontaneous
movement
what movement are we talking about here
the movement
within themselves the movement
in relation to each other
as thought as part of how they work
through
their
notion i suppose we could say right and
again uh phi viliga is the term that's
being used they're not vilkirk you know
it's uh
not arbitrary it's a free and
spontaneous movement
and then he says as then the movement of
the two sides is an intrinsic movement
meaning what intrinsic well
he tells you in the next um
few phrases it is something to be
considered on its own
account
considered in the sides themself
and then he says
it is initiated
by that side
there's two sides right
one is being for itself
and one has
being in itself
and it's on the side of the
in itself
that the initiative
is really going to take place both are
in movement
one of them is doing something
more
or earlier
than the other
metaphysically speaking
so he says it is uh initiated by that
side which is determined as possessing
being in itself is contrasted with the
other and this goes back to the previous
paragraph right we've got
you know two different sides we've got
being for itself we've got being in
itself and there was a middle term
between them here the middle term is the
conflict but the middle term before that
was existence in general dazainuba
helped right
and what's going to happen here so he
goes on and he says
this is depicted as a spontaneous act
but the necessity
for it's
externalization
and oison right
um and there's two terms here uh
externalization
alienation that are being used
basically for the same thing the
necessity for its externalization
lies in the notion lies in the if
uh the concept that being in itself
which is so determined
in the antithesis
has just for that reason no genuine
substance and now this is kind of
strange to say right being
uh
in itself
um
the on zigzagenda
the existing being
generating within itself
doesn't have
the independent
existence or subsistence that we stay in
that we would think that it has right
and typically there's a little bit of a
digression
there's two things to say here one is um
i get a lot of people saying being in
itself being for itself you know i just
want to wrap my heads around these how
they work in hegel can i say x about
being for itself an x about or why about
being in itself and my answer is always
it depends on where you are in the
dialectic
hegel is not using being in itself and
being for itself the way that say
jean-paul sartre
is later on in being in nothingness
these are both relational terms and
these are progressively developing terms
so being for itself in one passage may
not be exactly the same thing as being
for itself in another passage and
likewise with being in itself or
intrinsic beings it's sometimes
translated right and notice that that we
have you know on zigzag rather than you
know uh the on zeke or anzine right
and so we got to be a little careful
here that doesn't mean that we need to
make all sorts of fine distinctions it
just means that we need to pay attention
and look what's actually being said
rather than engaging in
acedesis as opposed to exegesis where we
bring our own
simplifying categories to the text to
try to
paste them on and make it nice and
simple for ourselves we need to follow
what is actually
being said here
and
the other thing i want to say is usually
as i mentioned it's portrayed as if the
being
in itself is you know kind of kind of
boring kind of mundane you know and then
the being for itself is the the cool
sexy part that does has the negativity
on its side well there's negativity in
being in itself here as well and this
one is going to progress
where being for itself is being a little
bit left behind right so coming back to
the text
he says
it's therefore that side which has not
being
for self but
simple being
you know
einfach a
straightforward being we could say
that uh
alienates
others or externalizes
itself from itself yields to death
thereby reconciles the absolute essence
with itself so in that one sentence
there's a lot of stuff going on there
right so it alienates itself from itself
zeke zebs and uicerts and this is on the
part of the
uh
the being in itself the
moment that has
this kind of essentiality this kind of
independent existence is upstanding a
dozen and it's going to turn that
diazine into a different kind of diazine
right
so
how does it do that by
yielding by giving into death
that is a
loss of its
essentiality
its independence
but also its dozen its existence itself
this is how it alienates itself from
itself it could go on
existing being
being what it is
in this conflict with the the other but
instead it
it allows itself
to be
killed destroyed
torn from itself
and he goes on and he says
by doing this
absolute essence which is you know what
these things are
supposed to be
dealing with absolute essence
essentiality
independent
is reconciled
there's there's a reconciliation
a re-harmonization
with itself
these two moments the for itself is in a
certain way benefiting
from this
so he goes on and he says
in this movement
it the the movement
away from the conflict itself and in the
yielding to death the
the externalizing the
alienating itself in this movement it
manifests itself as spirit
abstract essence
is alienated from itself and now the
term that's being used for alienation
and find it right being made friend
alien other right
and
what else happens
um it has natural existence
so it's its dozen is that of things in
the world uh human beings have bodies
they and this is coming from the in
itself right the for itself is not
providing this to it having bodies means
vulnerability to death
and then he goes on and he says
not only does it have natural existence
it has self-like
actuality
vehicle kite
realness
right it is that way and and now here's
where we we've already got a lot of
metaphysics going on here
here's where it becomes typically
hegelian and also
um you know deeply metaphysical he says
this otherness
being other or its sensuous presence is
taken
back again
by the second othering and posited as
superseded al hobana right as universal
it becomes universal by
doing this it becomes
what belongs to
each and every
of us
through this yielding to death and so
we've got a double othering happening
here a second other a first othering and
a second on on uh othering
and
there's different terms used for these
right
on design
anders viedem
sein being vietnam becoming
so
this is you know i would say pretty
important to pay close attention to
this otherness is taken back again by
the second othering so the other ring is
othered right the other ring of the
undersign
is now turned into a
becoming other right
and we can see that is what's going on
and here this this on design to each
other this
contradiction this
battle
of both sides
seems kind of static doesn't it is
transformed into something dynamic
so he goes on and he says
the essence has thereby come to be its
own self
is you know zeus
in its sensuous
presence
sensuous
means being part of the world being able
to be seen heard
smelled right
and what are we talking about here i
mean
we're talking about
this
important person who dies and is
resurrected jesus christ you know it's
kind of funny because the the idea that
a lot of people have of jesus is this
very sanitized figure
because they look at you know beautiful
paintings of him
and you know which are done for
devotional purposes but also you know
it's a way of depicting him and if he's
the glorified christ he should have some
holes in him right like hands and so
that you know inside so doubting thomas
could actually oops let's let's see
what's there if he's the crucified
christ he'll be more like the crucifixes
that you see in other countries the
united states a lot of them are pretty
sanitized there'll be a little bit of
blood around his head and a little bit
on his hands but you go to like you know
i saw this when i was in churches in
portugal that's a much more realistic
depiction this guy must have you know
had the crap beaten out of him was
pierced with wounds and there's going to
be lots and lots of blood and perhaps
even some gore well that is part of what
it means to have you know sensuous
presence
says the immediate existence of
actuality has ceased
to be something alien and external for
absolute essence absolute essence now
can
grasp it
since that existence is superseded is
universal it has been made agamayna and
this is where we get to this death
is therefore its resurrection
standing back up
quite literally
or standing up in a different way as
spirit as geist so now we have
the
uh death being
brought in as
an essential
moment
in addition to these moments
of what spirit is undergoing
and now we're ready to launch into this
massive paragraph 780.
you